bonsoir je suis enseignant et
photographe stamm confères de qualité la
première celle d'avoir du temps la
seconde celle d'observer constamment
tout le temps partout mon environnement
les personnes avec qui j'étais ravie et
ce matin encore je regardais mon petit
garçon il s'appelle diogène
il a deux ans j'ai déposé à la crèche il
a passé la porte de sa section il s'est
dirigé vers des jouets je ne lui ai pas
dit à un moment
diogène s'il te plaît joue faut savoir
qu'à deux ans l'apprentissage se fait
par le jeu à aucun moment je ne lui dis
diogène apprend je ne lui ai pas dit non
plus veux tu ta soir à cette table et
pendant huit heures à prendre non
naturellement il s'est dirigé vers ces
jeux puis je suis sortie de la crèche
est juste en face il ya une école
maternelle primaire
je me suis approché d'une vitre et j'ai
regardé j'ai regardé et j'ai
véritablement eu un effet madeleine de
proust
je me suis replongé dans mon passé et je
vous invite à faire ce voyage
aujourd'hui ici et maintenant fermez les
yeux fermés les yeux quelques minutes
fermer les yeux
replongez vous dans cette école
maternelle primaire dans laquelle vous
étiez à gauche en entrant un espace
classe des chaises des tables
le bureau du professeur sur le bureau du
professeur en gros taille crayon avec
une manivelle
il y avait sur les murs des tables de
multiplication des règles
orthographiques
il y avait vos productions personnelles
l'alphabet à droite dans la classe un
coin coussin avec une bibliothèque une
ludothèque vous pouviez vous y asseoir
après avoir fait un bon travail et
simplement prendre le temps de lire un
livre
il y avait peut-être un coin cuisine
vous avez réalisé vos première crêpe
vous y avez mangé votre première galette
des rois
vous avez donné d'ailleurs la couronne à
votre reine de l'époque
et puis au fond de la classe un coin un
coin jeu avec une grosse armoire
métallique ou bien était ce une porte en
bois dérobé avec deux dans des étagères
et des groupes de gouache une bouteille
en plastique coupée à moitié avec des
pinceaux dedans ouvrez les yeux
on a tous vécu cette école et puis vous
êtes entré en secondaire
quelle était votre environnement dans
l'enseignement secondaire des tables des
chaises un tableau quatre murs peut-être
était-il pain vous avez de la chance
moi j'ai connu les rideaux défraîchi
chauffage qui fonctionne en été et pas
en hiver qu'est ce qu'on a constaté au
fait qu'est ce qu'on constate dans ces
conditions en fait on constate un
changement d'environnement et en tant
qu'enseignant au début de l'enseignement
secondaire on constate aussi les
premiers gros décrochage en fait un
environnement jadis stimulant
sensorielle porter on arrive maintenant
en environnement cérébrale neutre
alors d'un ceux qui décrochent qu'est ce
que l'on fait on l'est réoriente vers ce
qu'on appelle le qualifiant leur
expliquant que c'est beaucoup plus
pragmatiques comme si l'enseignement
secondaire qui a mené après aux études
supérieures n'était pas pragmatique
comme si en fait être chirurgien ce
n'était pas pragmatique et renseigne ans
n'était pas pragmatique être ingénieur
ce n'était pas pragmatique
certains me diront oui mais on a besoin
d'un environnement neutre pour former
les cerveaux de demain vous avez ici une
photo assez connus qui est la photo
prise du bureau d'einstein juste après
sa mort moi je n'y vois pas une classe
de secondaire neutre et cérébrales j'y
vois du chaos
j'y vois un tableau sur lequel on a
écrit on a effacé j'y vois des livres
j'y vois un environnement que qui
portent intellectuellement
vous savez l'école telle que je la
connais ressemble à à peu près à cela
aussi propre à peu près cela les écoles
dans lesquelles je suis passé
globalement c'est l'environnement dans
lequel je travaille tous les jours
l'environnement il y a plusieurs siècles
celui mes prédécesseurs ressembler à
cela globalement toutes choses ont
changé en fait je crois que l'école a
toujours souffert de trois écueils
le premier c'est le rapport à l'erreur
l'école n'a jamais toléré l'erreur quand
vous étiez planté à l'école on a pris un
big rouge on vous a dit vous ne valez
rien surtout doublé à peu de choses près
et donc l'école dans sa transformation
de quel droit pourrait-elle elle même
faire des erreurs alors comment je pense
que dans l'école dans la transformation
de l'école elle a le droit aussi de
commettre d erreur d'essayer une
méthodologie de se planter et puis de
réessayer et c'est pas grave
deuxième écueil c'est le rapport au
contenu que l'école a toujours entretenu
une école a toujours baliser le contenu
qu'il fallait avoir à l'école qu'il
fallait apprendre
au début on appelait ça laisse à voir
maintenant on appelle ça les compétences
demain on appellera ça l'excellence mais
il se fait que en réalité les contenus
existants en dehors de l'école
ce n'est pas l'école qui inventaient les
sciences et pas l'école qui a inventé
les mathématiques les contenus préexiste
à l'école et existe en dehors de
celles-ci donc l'école en fait ne doit
pas déterminer les contenus doit être
une interface une interface entre un
environnement et un apprenant
on voit d'ailleurs que la pédagogie par
projets dans supérieur refait surface et
qu est-ce qu on impulse là on impulse
des méthodologies on dit à nos étudiants
faites ce que vous voulez travailler sur
le sujet qui vous plaît par contre je
vais vous enseigner des méthodologies
car les contenus s'en vont mais les
méthodologies elle elle reste et puis
l'école a toujours été fondée sur le
mode industriel nos élèves étaient vus
comme des produits sur un banc de
montage linéaire où chacun de manière
cloisonnée donne son cours regardez dans
les écoles 50 minutes d'un cours 50
minutes d'un autre cours et puis 50
minutes encore dans troisième alors que
le paradigme du numérique change
radicalement tout ça le numérique c'est
c'est véritablement la pensée en
arborescence c'est une espèce de
profusion d'idées qui vient de partout
et l'école ne réplique pas ce mode
c'est la raison pour laquelle je
m'attelle à proposer un modèle scolaire
un modèle scolaire dit modèle
environnemental
mon but c'est de voir quels sont tous
les paramètres environnementaux sur
lesquels on peut agir et qui vont
impacter positivement et durablement les
apprentissages et c'est une façon dans
l'école n'a pas encore procédé est
pourquoi en fait l'école a toujours
reproduit son schéma de fonctionnement
or pour innover il faut emprunter des
voies incertaine et c'est la raison pour
laquelle aujourd'hui je me permets de
citer saint jean de la croix
qui dit pour aller où tu ne sais pas il
faut aller par où tu ne sais pas et
c'est ce petit chemin que je vous
propose le modèle environnemental
mais déjà le focus sur le lab ce qu'on
appelle le lab c'est notre environnement
notre environnement physique notre
environnement spatial qu'est ce qui se
passe dès lors que l'on voit l'espace
classe non plus comme juste en espace
classe on y apprend mais comme un
environnement on développe déjà
l'empathie entre des élèves mais aussi
entre l'élève et le professeur et puis
on polarise positivement le rapport à
l'apprentissage on élève ne va pas en
place
juste pour s'asseoir sur un fauteuil
tout à fait un confortable et parfois à
prendre des matières qu'ils n'apprécient
pas bien que il faille parfois à prendre
simplement des matières on n'apprécie
pas
mais à tout le moins on polaris
positivement l'espace parce que dedans
on peut il discute et on peut y lire
on peut y jouer on peut y apprendre
certes on peut faire plein d'autres
choses
et dès lors que notre environnement
devient stable on peut l'exploiter
l'exploiter et remettre dans notre jeu
scolaire les sens qu'ont utilisé jadis
et qu'on n'utilise plus ré exploiter le
visuel réexploiter l'olfactif exploiter
l'auditif à partir du moment où vous
explique mon environnement
j'ai déjà des nouvelles opportunités
pédagogique par exemple si je my maps la
matière si gmail maps toutes les
matières suivi par les élèves et que mon
environnement est constitué d'un grand
tableau blanc partout sur les murs
qu'est ce qui va se passer je vais voir
se développer tout au long de l'année
toutes les matières visuellement comme
un cerveau en expansion et à la fin
j'aurais une forme de syncrétisme de
tout ce que j'aurais appris durant cette
année est visuellement cela est porteur
vient ensuite vient aussi la possibilité
alors d'exploiter ces deux nouvelles
techniques pédagogiques liés par exemple
au management
vous savez on apprend à nos élèves à
gérer des projets très bien super
maintenant avec un environnement visuel
par exemple je peux utiliser des
matrices de gestion de projet utiliser
des post it et cela perdure dans le
temps vient ensuite le holisme le
holisme c'est remettre l'accent sur le
grand tout que forment une classe c'est
déjà développer l'intelligence
collective l'intelligence collective
c'est une forme d'intelligence
supérieure à la forme d intelligence
supérieure à la somme des intelligences
individuelles qui constitue un espace
équine et notamment de l'interaction de
ces différents intelligence vous savez
on ne mise pas non plus sur
l'interdisciplinarité
or si j'ai un environnement visuellement
porter je peux visuellement et
explicitement réaliser les liens entre
les différentes matières sauver un
professeur de théorie financière
m'expliquer qu'on engage par exemple des
physiciens dents
bang pourquoi parce que le court
l'évolution du cours de bourse évolué
aléatoirement avec le même mouvement
qu'une poussière dans l'air en tant que
professeur de français moi j'ai tendance
à dire que je vois aussi là dedans
beaucoup de poésie
dix formations professionnelles et puis
il ya des liens de latin et la chimie
entre la biologie le cours d'éducation
physique
il y a des liens également entre les
statistiques et la philosophie
certes on essaie de développer de façon
cérébrale et pourquoi pas les voir ces
liens et pouvoir véritablement tisser ce
lien dans notre environnement visuel
vient ensuite l'ouverture je vous ai dit
l'école est en décalage par rapport à la
société
notre école nous forme à une société
mais on se rend compte que elle ne nous
feront pas la bonne société
l'école projette un modèle de société
qui n'est pas le modèle qui existe en
dehors de celle ci l'ouverture c'est se
dire que l'école doit faire des allers
retours entre elle même et la société
s'ouvrir par exemple faire venir des
intervenants extérieurs
c'est une première chose mais aussi
pourquoi pas et on le voit apparaît dans
le supérieur
implémenter des espaces de coworking
dans des environnements d'apprentissage
or certains me diront que le grand
capital rentrer dans l'école que c'est
dangereux
je ne crois pas je ne crois pas parce
que les environnements de coworking sont
très porteurs de diversité et puis ça
permet à un étudiant de voir qu'est ce
que le monde professionnel
et puis pour le professionnel ça permet
de se dire tiens comment puis-je nourrir
mon mon projet créatif avec l'aide d'un
jeune cerveau qui n'a pas encore subi le
rouleau compresseur de certaines écoles
puis je pense également que l'ouverture
ça rappelle à luminy à l'humilité de
tous ceux qui enseignent
je vous ai dit vous laisse avoir toutes
les compétences existent en dehors de
l'école parfois ce que l'on enseigne
c'est un grain de sable dans l'immensité
du savoir qu'ils existent donc je pense
sincèrement que dans cet aller retour
entre l'école et la société
il faut aussi se réapproprier une forme
d'humilité quand on est enseignant bien
la dernière partie la connexion
l'intégration des technologies de
l'information et de la communication
l'éthique dans l'environnement scolaire
sais pas si vous connaissez des profs si
vous leur avez déjà posé la question de
l'intégration des tic dans
l'environnement scolaire
mais si vous voulez je les repas de
famille et y mettre une mauvaise
ambiance
je pense que c'est la meilleure question
à poser en fait l'école n'a jamais su
s'adapter
en tout cas elle n'a pas encore réussi à
s'adapter alors on a essayé de s'adapter
on a par exemple remplacer les tableaux
noirs par des tvi des tableaux blancs
interactifs et on va subsister dans un
même espace des éléments qui entraîne un
petit peu un paradoxe c'est à dire qu'on
voit apparaître de débit
l'évolution il estrade lestrade qui
marquent quand même la zone du
professeur et la zone de l'élève la zone
de celui qui sait et la zone de celui
qui ne sait pas la zone de celui qui de
manière hiérarchique mans supérieur va
enseigner de manière linéaire et
unilatérale à la petite tête à remplir
alors que les technologies de
l'information la communication nous
permettre de faire des choses puis
centre dans l'enseignement peut-être pas
d'apprendre une compétence mais en tout
cas de la consolider de l'améliorer de
la démultipliée si dès lors je transmets
une compétence un élève celle de
s'organiser c'est de faire des
recherches
les technologies vont lui permettre ça
donne à voir plus facile à développer
cette compétence et c'est en ça que la
technologie pour moi on doit vraiment se
la réapproprier et voir comment ce
qu'elle peut démultiplier des
compétences que l'on acquiert l école il
y aussi ce rapport aux technologies pour
un jeune en tant qu'enseignant on se
doit également de les éduquer et de leur
dire que la technologie ce n'est pas que
le divertissement pour beaucoup des
jeunes que j'ai en secondaire 1
smartphone sert aux réseaux sociaux et à
faire des snapshot dégueulasse alors
qu'en réalité d'une bombe technologique
dans leur poche ils peuvent ils ont une
mémoire visuelle
ils peuvent photographier tout ce qu'ils
voient ils peuvent s'organiser ils
peuvent partager des fichiers ils
peuvent partager d'aider des calendriers
ils peuvent avoir accès au savoir et une
quantité énorme de savoir et pourtant
non ils font de vieux celle fille
dégueulasse
je caricature pour l'exemple évidemment
mais je pense que derrière cela il y a
quand même un bon fond de vérité alors
qu'est ce qu'on fait avec ces quatre
éléments
il ya trois ans j'ai mené une petite
expérience en tout cas un petit projet
il n'a rien plaisanter ce modèle de
classe dans une école il y avait un
espace d'apprentissage un petit salon
avec une bibliothèque bibliothèque
je suis prof de français je donne cours
dans des classes où il n'y a pas de
livre c'est comme enseigner la musique
dans des classes où il n'y a pas
d'instrument un peu de choses près vous
avez donc une bibliothèque un accès à
des ordinateurs il avait une cuisine une
machine à café une machine à thé ou d'un
point de vue budget ils avaient tous
d'apporter donc même la question du
budget n'importe pas on a remarqué deux
choses la première les résultats n'ont
jamais été aussi bons vraiment le taux
de réussite a explosé la seconde ligne
lgv qui est venu me voir un mercredi
après-midi et elle m'a dit monsieur oui
je restais à l'école la première chose
que la première question que je me suis
posée c'est de savoir est ce qu'elle est
et en retenue en fait non elle voulait
simplement passer du temps dans ce local
dans cette classe
j'ai plus envie de l'appeler classe
parce qu'elle s'y sentait bien et parce
qu'elle avait envie d'apprendre dedans
et là je me suis dit si en changeant
notre environnement scolaire on parvient
à faire en sorte que des élèves nous
demande pour rester à l'école parce
qu'ils s'y sentent bien
n'at-on pas là réussi un grand défi
majeur vous savez je suis pour un
décloisonnement des apprentissages
qu'on arrête de se dire il y a des
moments où on apprend et des moments on
n'apprend pas je suis vraiment pour que
ces apprentissages pour que chacun soit
en apprenant perpétuelle qu'on apprenne
en tout lieu et en tout temps et pour
cela l'environnement scolaire peut
impacter ce rapport aux apprentissages
et ce soir je vais vous donner non pas
un devoir mais plutôt une proposition
parce qu'il n'est pas obligé de le faire
vous invite à rentrer chez vous dans
votre environnement professionnel
simplement considérer celui ci et vous
dire tiens que puis-je modifié dans mon
environnement qui va me permettre
d'améliorer mes apprentissages s du
visuel s2 l'olfactif s2 l'auditif à vous
de choisir
et puis cette volonté que j'ai de
transformer l'école peut-être qu'elle
vient d'une angoisse l'angoissent d'un
jeune papa parce que aujourd'hui diogène
à deux ans dans six mois il ira à
l'école j'aimerais reprendre les mots de
saint jean de la croix
me pencher vers le petit garçon et lui
dire ceci tu sais mon grand faisons de
l'école ce qu'elle n'est pas en
empruntant des chemins que nous ne
connaissons pas je vous remercie
[Musique]